hi i'm adam wray and i'm jessie may and
welcome to
assume the position this is a show that
takes a silly look at a sexy topic yeah
sex by
webster's dictionary is defined as
either two of the major forms of
individuals that occur in many species
and that are distinguished respectively
as female or male especially on the
basis of their reproductive organs and
structures
that's a mouthful
we're gonna look at this book of sexual
positions cover up the names of the
positions
try to guess what they are ready go
ah the uh girl on girl
the butthole trumpet the periscope
the whole trip the thermometer oh
oh her tongue is a thermometer wow love
is love that i want to get pregnant
the cousin's birthday party oh god it's
so creepy
what are your family parties like
they're weird catch me if you can't
what is this looks like what's that what
does it look like what symbol does it
look like
it looks like a like the hitler symbol i
don't want to say it because it's wrong
oh well their legs
swash the sex swastika god just for
just because the way it looks i am
pilates and plow
the bar mitzvah magic show the silent
treatment okay yeah you're not talking
to it no you're not talking
how can your head's in different ends of
the room the
tantric tail
[Music]
what is that one again the
are you vegan tell me about your dreams
and passions
the paraplegic let's end on that one
the fun house mirror how that's weird
there's nothing fun about it there's
nothing fun about that elsie has a
really great posture though look at that
straight leg
impressive her tits are very pointy our
guest this week is one of my best
friends he's hilarious he's a regular at
the comedy store he's also on a show on
e-network called
what the fashion give it up for mr
justin martindale
[Applause]
how are you doing you don't have arms
that's how you kill a cat just with
yeah yeah i let it out yeah how are you
jay great good to see you you look beat
to the nines what are you
thank you yeah so um so sex
that's what we're here to tell you yeah
yes do you remember your first time oh
yeah it was terrifying
what was it um well which one do you
want
the very first time no i mean boy or
girl both
who was the first well why we're all
here
uh it was it was a girl i was 19. yeah
great
yeah is that late a lot of blood a lot
of tears yikes before
before what before you had sex yeah this
was dark oh no no it was during yeah it
was her first time as well i was like
was she menstruating or did you hear
no no you know she's got a baby arm down
there you broke a hymen
yeah that's what my indian name is
hyman wait so
where was it at your folks house at her
house
no it was in my apartment like a person
okay
loser virginia at home with your parents
people have done it
people have done it nobody here it was
definitely wasn't me with my single mom
well love uh thanks for not coming
downstairs
at the basement of your folks home
thanks ron thanks brian
thanks for opening the door even though
it was somewhat cracked in a jar because
that's the way you had me do things
oh wait okay so at your apartment yeah
and did you know it was about to go down
when she came over
i planned it yeah i knew it i was like
this is it
did you plan it to get it over with or
were you like this like
you thought you were into chicks at that
time in your life yeah i mean it was the
90s you know
yeah and then what happened immediately
afterwards uh
comforting and regret yeah yeah because
you'd pick the wrong song
i picked the wrong sex yeah
whoa we got a sound bite
could she tell like that you weren't
into it i don't know i think it was just
we both didn't know what we were doing
yeah and we were just like is this
is that like it was like is this it is
this is what
yeah afterwards
it's the worst puzzle ever yeah i think
it's the way all firsts are they're like
awkward and terrible they're not meant
to be magical and beautiful and
something you
remember fondly yeah there's tears
crying in blood
oh god oh my god
oh my god this is us all the time yeah
this is all day early i love it
well jay there's um there's a lot of
people that have been um
sending in questions because uh you know
there's a lot of
sexual mysteries out there and people
are dealing with their own [ __ ]
and uh and so we we decided to take them
on and try to give them some perspective
um if you'd like to help us i'd love to
uh in a segment we call
that advice this is from detroit
michigan of course it is
carrie writes every time i have an
orgasm i fart
it's so embarrassing and i boo moo wait
am i what
am i doomed oh am i i do move
and i boo mood my boo
she does every time she comes she farts
when she has an orgasm
yeah is she doomed you ever have that
happen is that a problem with like dudes
what just farting during yeah
do you just do you just how do you yeah
how do you do you laugh or is it just
normal
i don't know like hold on i'm really
trying to think about this yeah
because when you're pushing up air in
places you know bound to be noises yeah
there's gonna be noises and slaps and
maybe a neighbor going
i can hear you should we call the cops
i i have a solution kegels yeah
tunnel sex science that'll do what
that'll keep the the air
you know backdraft to a minimum if you
just tighten up the pipes
no pun intended no every time she farts
she knows well he needs to know that
he's making something right it's an
indicator
yeah yeah so maybe a way
what would dave and attaboro say about
this behold
the mighty wind tunnel
[Music]
notice how she releases gas after she
climaxes four more weeks of winter
the male penis is barbed and ready
carved
jesus yeah no animals animals have
barb's penises like an eel
right he does like to get high and watch
planet what does that mean
and i think i'm speaking for everybody
other than you two what does barbed mean
it's like it's like barb it's like a
woman named barb guy
it's a hook like a because you know
women females in nature sometimes don't
want to stick around so the man
hooks them oh so they can't run away and
so the semen can
impregnate them it's a it's a how come
we're not talking about
that yeah i'll fix and assume the
position
barbed it i mean that's a great drag
name
all right to the stage barb dicks
our next question comes from oakland
california trevor says i had a dream i
had sex with a dude
does that make me gay no
that does not make you gay that makes
you sexually confident i like that
and it's like i feel like if you have a
dream like that you shouldn't wake up
and be like
i had a dream i had a dream actually
last week that i had sex with a woman
and how did that make you feel when you
woke up uh like i still got it who was
it do you remember what it was don't
remember who it was
olympia dukakis uh no finally
no it wasn't it was somebody that i know
and i recently had a dream that i had
sex with a friend of ours
cool i'm not gonna tell you
welcome to our new segment who did
jessica
no it was it was it was a it was [ __ ] it
it was andrew santino
oh cheeto and i was just kind of like
what
yeah and i woke up and was like uh and i
think it's just because he posts a lot
of like homoerotic stuff on his
and he's very fit and he's very strange
he's very fit but i had a dream about it
i was just like wait a minute that was
weird but then i'm like we're friends
we're good yeah it was consensual in my
dream in an apocalypse
yeah i feel like consensual my dream
that's good right you feel good about
that i love it
are we in this together yes welcome to a
woman's world
it's only consensual in my dream coming
out on netflix next year my netflix
special
so there's a lot of stories out there
sexually that are making the headlines
we're going to talk about some of them
right now
in florida i'm already i don't know
all the great sex news comes out of
florida someone [ __ ] the gator what is
it
in florida a hypnotherapist accused of
having sex
uh with his patient robert andrew
nichols one of his female patients
um engaged in sex therapy and ritual
magic
in an august uh appointment yep um
nicholls unexpectedly kissed this female
client on the lips the nichols suggested
to the woman that they'd go to his house
and uh continue the appointment they
they had sex and according to the report
nichols reportedly stopped
charging for his services wow
see i mean he said original magic
ritual magic of the uh that's all
[ __ ]
it's like hypnotherapy yeah that's
that's such
that that sounds like the creepiest way
to i don't remember
i was hypnotized it sounds like just oh
i'm awake now
where am i i'm here this is this panic
room i made
am i on this show it's just my garage
quit being weird god
yeah i think that's [ __ ] i think i
think she totally
i think she got caught yes i think she
went to go see
this therapist and then it went into
therapy she's like he used to lose this
and
harold i just don't remember a thing oh
tragen
i just i wish i could there was so many
were there any smells or sounds
so many doors to open and apparently it
was going on for months that they were
doing it for months
okay yeah and he he just never he just
never snapped his fingers
she just hypnotized for months when i
say caterpillar you will come back to
consciousness
a reverend of the church of cyprus said
last week pregnant moms liking anal sex
is what makes kids gay he said
homosexuality is usually a problem
transfer to a fetus when the pregnant
woman has anal sex and enjoys it
someone doesn't know biology and anatomy
the semen goes in the butt to the vagina
what
that's what it just said i missed that
episode of magic school bus
exactly come on where are we going mrs
big boy
straight to hell
or anal sex makes kids gay so when a
woman is pregnant has sex
but the the dick sends magic messages to
the feet
through the butt yeah you should have
answered
you in the fetus you look tired you know
what exactly coming from the butt
right behind you turn around put it in
your butt every weekend
oh would you say to me well maybe you're
right maybe i will make him gay
so justin we have a bunch of positions
written down on a piece of paper in this
mug we have not seen
you're going to scramble in there grab
one scramble
scribble it's a word uh choose one you
can show it to the audience
and then you're going to draw and we
have to guess okay get in there
put your black i am oh
the password is
so good at voices all right justin
you've got the
name of the position we don't know we're
going to put 90 seconds in the sand
and ready draw
you're so intense justin uh box box of
emotions
staircase door uh
that's a tooth toilet bowl a hot hot box
oh wow it's a fridge no there's a toilet
that's the we're looking at the
blueprint of the house it's a door
that's a a woman's throwing up in the
toilet nope she's bent over the juice
juice
hot fire the house is on fire hot tits
hot tits
okay um but um
okay hole key key hole
fill my holes sperm that's a sperm an
egg and an egg that's absolutely
the exploded ovary oh [ __ ]
damn it we weren't close at all it is
the porta hottie oh yeah that's really
good though
yeah it's a port-a-potty potty it's like
a porta hottie
oh man they're like hot i was like uh
that's the green
is that like it's open yes it's a porta
potty that's like when we went hiking
that one weekend
yes i was like
well justin you gave it a valiant effort
we couldn't get it but we want to send
you home
not empty-handed okay so you will be
getting a 10 gift certificate
to jamba juice yeah thanks this show get
your greens
get your greens well thanks for watching
give it up one more time for our guest
justin martin down
our audience where they can find you uh
you can find me on instagram
justin martindale and on twitter at
chessmartindale and uh you can follow
uh and you can find me also um at a
bathroom stall of your choice
on your show on your show what the
fashion
what the fashion and sir this is the
ladies room
oh yeah yes please that'll be on nbc
this fall
and if you guys have questions you want
some bad advice on email it to atp
allthingscomedy.com or use the hashtag
badvice yeah yeah good job justin
you did good yeah yeah yeah yeah you can
also find me at a wheelchair accessible
bathroom stall
thanks for watching we'll see you next
week where we assume
the position where she get next week
is that what they say sounded like
somebody's christmas
we'll see you next week
hair gosh there's still like your
dentures are [ __ ]
caleb can you bring me my mouth
[Applause]
goodnight everybody thanks for watching
this show
caleb can you bring me my
can that be a new segment
you